♪ Цвіте терен, цвіте терен,
та й цвіт опадає. ♪
♪ Хто з любов'ю й не знається,
той горя й не знає. ♪
♪ Хто з любов'ю й не знається, ♪
♪ Той горя не знає. ♪
Лиман — моє рідне село.
Тут народилися мої батьки,
народилися мої дідусі й бабусі.
Задонецьке полуницею славиться,
Балаклійський район — цибулею.
А ми просом прославились.
♪ А в наше село Купало прийшло, ♪
♪ Купало прийшло — радість принесло! Ух! ♪
♪ А наше Купало на вигоні спало, ♪
♪ Сонечко зійшло — за село пішло! Ух! ♪
Ранок у нас починався з пісень.
Усі в мене теж співали:
і сестра, і брат якось з дитинства.
Батько мене учив з дитинства
співати, ще до школи.
Якісь весілля, якесь сватання...
Люди збиралися, і був хор,
прекрасний хор звучав.
А були іще баяністи,
ці були взагалі нарозхват.
Підождіть-підождіть!
[сміються]
♪ Ой, на горі жовта бляха,
ой, на горі жовта бляха. ♪
♪ Полюбила дівка ляха,
полюбила дівка ляха. ♪
♪ Не так ляха, як Данила,
Не так ляха, як Данила. ♪
♪ А в Данила душа мила!
А в Данила душа мила! ♪
♪ Чоловіче, бійся Бога!
Чоловіче, бійся Бога! ♪
♪ Летять миски до порога,
Летять миски до порога. ♪
♪ Не так миски, як тарілки,
Не так миски, як тарілки. ♪
♪ За чужії краще жінки,
За чужії краще жінки! ♪
♪ Нема миски, ні тарілки!
Нема миски, ні тарілки! Ух! ♪
Тільки там «бо чужії».
Батьки мої співали.
У мене мама гарно дуже співала,
батько — не дуже.
Але по маминій лінії, там брати,
і вони співали оці пісні.
Я потім почала згадувати їх.
І от я ж кажу: з дитинства
це мене супроводжувало.
Обрала професію — на режисерський.
Культпросвіт, це зрозуміло.
І в інституті співала, і кругом,
і де б я не була.
А сюди приїхала, назад
вернулась додому,
а тут же ж ця «Калинонька».
І пішли до бабушки́,
а бабушки́ років моїх батьків.
А вони від своїх бабусь,
а ті — від своїх бабусь.
От вони якось так передавались,
передавались, складалися.
І мелодію ж вони, оці закарлюки
всілякі, вони ж самі...
Як-от кажуть, їхали чумаки,
їдуть по сіль, а дорога довга...
І як повільно вони їдуть,
такі й пісні в них були
чумацькі: протяжні, довгі.
І от я почала
згадувати ці пісні ще,
тому що ми зазвичай естрадні
любили співати, знаєте, як воно?
А це воно саме глибоко:
ти його співаєш, на себе
перекладаєш якось,
і воно зачіпає
такі струни твоєї душі!
Дуже глибоко! Просто…
Ну, я так розумію...
[сміється]
От ножик у мене,
мотузочка в мене.
Так, зараз я...
♪ Піду в садочок,
нарву квіточок, ♪
♪ Гей, гей, гей,
та й нарву квіточок! ♪
А далі?
♪ Нарву квіточок,
сплету віночок, ♪
♪ Гей, гей, гей! ♪
Улюблене «гей», так?
♪ Та й сплету віночок! ♪
Раз-два-три. Раз.
Оце от бабусі
в одному кутку жили,
і ми до них йшли
і там співали.
А як просо?
Скучно ж чистити. От і співають.
І ми за бабусями тягнемо.
І пісня така в нас
теж була, про просо.
Мовляв, «просо прибираю і Василя
дожидаю», такого плану.
«Просо прибираю і Василя дожидаю».
Отак колектив цей фольклорний
у наших бабусь склався.
Переважно ці люди були...
Вони між собою навіть
мали родинні зв'язки.
У кожної було господарство, кози, все.
А де виступати —
вони все кидали і їхали з нами.
♪ Ой, на горі монастир,
під горою школа, ♪
♪ Одна дівка ж і краща всіх,
вона плаче з горя! ♪
♪  В неї батько, як цвіт —
зав'язав їй білий світ, ♪
♪ В неї мати ж як зоря —
рано заміж віддала! ♪
Усі пісні, які старовинні,
довгі й сумні.
Про долю жіночу,
яка була,
я думаю, під таким
кулаком чоловіка.
Доля жіноча була така важка.
Заміж віддавали ж,
бачте, як раніше?
Не хоче дівчина,
а «заміж іди за багатого».
Переважно пісні такі, журливі.
Рекрутські.
Тому що ходили хлопці
в солдати, довго служили.
Козацькі пісні.
Раніше бабушки́ співали —
багатоголосся було.
А ми могли вловити як:
перший голос, другий голос.
Як бабусі наші казали:
«Та легко ти співаєш» —
це високий голос,
«А це важко» —
це низький голос.
Бабусі навіть не знали,
що це було багатоголосся.
Просто їм дано так.
Такий музичний слух у бабусь був.
Вони теж не навчались,
музичної освіти не мали.
Але вони так відчували
себе й одна одну,
що всі голоси зливалися.
Та брала нижче,
та — ще нижче.
Хоча вони не знали,
що по музичній освіті
це ідуть якісь там партії.
Вони цього не знали.
♪ Тече річка невеличка
понад Слободою, ♪
♪ Взяла дівка нові відра,
пішла за водою, ♪
пішла за водою. ♪
♪ Коло Марино́ньки ходили дівоньки, ♪
♪ Стороною дощик іде, ♪
♪ Стороною та й на мою руженьку червону! ♪
По всій Україні святкується
оце купальське свято.
У ніч, тобто ввечері 6 липня.
З шостого і на сьоме.
Це народне старовинне-престаровинне,
дуже давнє свято.
Воно ще до християнства було,
є і залишиться ним.
От настає вечір, нас мами,
бабушки збирають на вигонах.
І коло дерева...
Віночки, це ж так красиво було.
Там квіточки чіпляли
на цю вишеньку. От...
І я з дитинства пам'ятаю,
що оце ми Купала справляли.
Це скрізь було, розумієте?
А взагалі, це день сонячного...
Сонцевороту.
Тобто сонце ніби повертається
вже на зиму,
і, як-то кажуть,
літо вже йде на спад.
— Привіт, дорога!
— Привіт!
[цілуються]
Давай. Зараз хлопців діждемося.
Собачко, не гавкай!
— Проходьте.
— Він вже й не гавкає, все.
Правда, у мене тут
апартаменти малі.
«Твої апартаменти» не треба.
[іронізує]
[сміється]
— А голий борщ пахне!
— Та я ж не доварила.
У нас рибальське село.
Коли ловилася велика риба,
голова із неї просто-таки
була ніби зайва.
І варився голий борщ.
На шматки рубалася та голова,
багато цибулі, моркви так,
щоб була тоненько нарізана, томату,
і все це вариться
досить коротко.
Риба ж недовго вариться.
Зате дається настоятися.
Щоб настоялася
десь у холодному місці,
щоб був свій специфічний смак.
Взагалі-то, риба корисна.
А якщо зварити такий голий борщ,
коли він настоїться,
там лаврушка,
там кропик, там цибулька,
там томат,
оцей колір такий.
Це приємно їсти.
Смакують у нас усі!
♪ Ой, на горі монастир,
під горою школа, ♪
♪ Одна дівка ж і краща всіх,
вона плаче з горя. ♪
♪ В неї батько, як цвіт —
поламав їй білий світ, ♪
♪ В неї мати ж як зоря —
рано заміж віддала! ♪
Дівчата, відкривайте!
Це наші дві з колективу.
Було десять людей в колективі.
І залишилось...
Дивіться, яких я гостей вам веду!
[гавкає пес]
— Привіт, бабо Надю!
— Привіт.
Привіт, привіт, сонечко, привіт.
— Не виходьте! Чи на лавочку?
— Ні, давай на лавочку.
— На лавочку?
— Ми вже сиділи, ми тільки що зайшли.
Бабушка Дуся, золота ви наша!
Були ж колись артисти,
та ото ж ми й співали.
Я пісню почула,
як вони виступали,
я дивилася пісню і згадала ту пісню:
♪ В саду ходила, цвіти збирала,
кого любила, причарувала. ♪
♪ В саду ходила, в саду гуляла,
В нас і корови були,
і свині були, і кози були, все.
А ми їздили виступати.
Ми туди поїдемо,
хоч розвіємося!
Кидали все!
А тепер і згадали.
У нас пісні з протя́гом.
Раніше повз нас
їздили по сіль чумаки.
Сідають на вози
і наші пісні співають.
Поки доїхали —
пісня закінчилась.
Протяжна довга пісня.
♪ Ой, сиділа Сашенька край віконця, ♪
♪ Виглядала Сашенька чорноморця, ♪
♪ Виглядала Сашенька чорноморця. ♪
Дерева ж без коріння не буває.
У нас (я там робила) така
композиція була: дерево, коріння.
І коріння — це були наші бабушки́,
а потім далі йшли ми,
а потім далі йшли
на гілках, на стінці...
А потім ми робили
фотографії, колажі...
І тобто, справді,
без коріння ж дерево не росте,
і потім воно й не цвіте,
і потім і не родить воно!
Як коріння є,
то так вже й ми.
І я вважаю, що от село
зберігає ці традиції, розумієте?
Саме село!
Поки ми ще живі,
оце старше покоління,
поки ми оце розказуємо
нашим внукам, розумієте?
Вони радіють,
вони тягнуться до цього.
Ця традиція ніколи не вмре.
♪ Ой, горе жити,
ой, лебедику, самому, ♪
♪ Ой, чи поросте,
ой, біле пір'я по йому? ♪